in October 2000 the president of Iraq's
Saddam Hussein announced they would no
longer be selling oil in U.S dollars
only in Euros so when Hussein decided to
start selling oil in Euros instead of
dollars the US wasn't too happy by
February 2003 he has sold over 3 billion
barrels of oil for 26 billion euros a
month later the U.S invaded Iraq in an
operation ironically called operation
Iraqi Freedom they overthrew Saddam and
by June just four months later the
country was back to selling oil in
dollars years later a number of U.S
officials started to let the truth seep
out former head of U.S operations in
Iraq General John abbazade said of
course it's about oil we can't really
deny that former fed chairman Alan
Greenspan wrote in his Memoir that quote
I'm certain that is politically
inconvenient to acknowledge what
everyone knows the Iraq war is largely
about oil End quotes and former Defense
secretary Chuck Hagel said the same in
2007. quote people say we're not
fighting for oil of course we are End
quotes click the link in the pin comment
to learn more